here in Los Angeles windy lately in Los
Angeles yeah Santa Ana winds past few
days it's been so windy there's all
kinds of stuff getting kicked up in the
wind and man my allergies are really bad
and medication doesn't even help Kona
have if you tried CBD yet is that CBD
that's the compound that's extracted
from marijuana plants yeah yeah exactly
no thanks um I'm not interested we have
it but C D is our CBD is totally organic
it cured my anxiety you really should
try it okay I'm just Trish what's going
on why is everyone around the office
pushing CBD all of a sudden well it's
because of this new business I invest it
in it's called have you tried CBD have
you tried CBD is the company that helps
people ask other people if they've tried
CBD let me get this straight so you
recommend CBD brands no we just ask
people if they've tried CBD so there's
no product at all well of course there
is we send you a box of cue cards it
includes key phrases like have you tried
CBD and don't worry it's not weed and my
yoga teacher used it on her baby
are you saying Andy are you saying you
invested in this this this sounds like a
scam Oh Conan you clearly aren't a
numbers guy how many people have
recently asked you if you've tried CBD
well I got to be honest a few I rest my
case
best 400 grand I've ever spent stop wait
a minute stop the music stop it Andy who
told you to invest in this my accountant
and she never steers me wrong I'm gonna
call her right now and then she'll
explain to you hey Mary
yeah can you explain to Conan why
investing in a company that tells people
about telling other people about CBD is
a good idea see Andy we have the same
accountant
[Applause]
[Laughter]
have you tried CBD
have you tried CBD does not actually
sell CBD we just ask people if they want
to learn how to ask other people if
they've tried CBD
[Applause]